(crowd chattering indistinctly)
- So good afternoon everyone.
I'm Kim Goff-Crews and it is my privilege
to welcome you here today
as we honor our veterans.
Now, before we begin, I would like
to thank the Yale Police
Department Color Guard
for presenting the colors
and express our deep gratitude
to the Quinnipiac people
for this land on which we stand.
It is my pleasure to warmly
welcome the students,
faculty, staff, and alumni
who are with us today
who have served and who are
preparing to serve our country.
We are grateful for the freedoms
and privileges that your
sacrifices have made possible.
Each member of our veterans
community contributes
to the vibrant culture of our university.
During our ceremony, you will hear
from a veteran leader
and a current student,
and we will honor a former staff person
who has supported and
advocated for Yale veterans.
Our speakers and our
honoree represent commitment
to honor and country to our veterans
and to those who care for
them and support them.
So we will start and I will now,
my pleasure to introduce
President Peter Salovey.
(audience applauding)
(Peter and Kim speak indistinctly)
- Thank you, Vice President Goff-Crews.
Appreciate that introduction.
Thank you all for being here,
and it gives me great pleasure
to see so many members
of the Yale community gathered
for our commemoration of Veterans Day.
It's a privilege especially
to extend a warm welcome
to current and former servicemen
and servicewomen who
are here with us today.
Why don't we recognize
all those in the service?
(Peter and audience applauding)
So for over three
centuries, Yale students,
faculty, staff, and alumni have answered,
dutifully and with
distinction, the call to serve.
The university's proud tradition
of service began with
the Revolutionary War
and it includes nearly 30,000 Yalies
who served in the First
and Second World Wars
and in Korea and in Vietnam.
And now the tradition continues.
It continues through
those who are enlisted
in the Reserve Officers'
Training Corps on campus,
as well as the many
veterans in our community.
And ceremonies like this one remind us
of the tremendous sacrifices
our veterans have made
to keep the peace in a world
that has become a more dangerous place.
In the words of former Secretary of State
and Yale honorary degree recipient,
the late Madeleine Albright,
"While democracy in the long run
"is the most stable form of government,
"it is in the short run
among the most fragile."
The price of liberty is noted
by the eminent Wendell Phillips
and many others is internal vigilance.
Around us, threats to democracy,
stoked increasingly by disinformation
and the division that it sows,
demand our utmost vigilance.
Standing watch are
those who sit before us.
Every veteran here today understands
that the essential values
in which we believe
so deeply require sacrifice.
In thinking of how the
veterans assembled here
this afternoon exemplify
our highest ideals,
I'm reminded of what Yale looks for
and more particularly whom it looks for.
Several decades ago, University
President Kingman Brewster
memorably distilled the
Yale admissions process as,
this his words, "a combination
of looking for those
"with a zest to stretch
the limits of their talents
"and those with an
outstanding public motivation.
"We have to make the
hunchy choice," he said,
"as to whether or not the
candidate for admission is likely
"to be a leader in whatever
they end up doing."
So let there be no doubt
that with each of our Yale veterans,
that with each of you who have set out
to improve the world for
this and future generations,
we got it right.
Yale made the right decision.
You have rewarded our hunch
and most importantly, you
have represented the best
of humanity with your heroism.
And so for this, you have
our deepest gratitude.
You have our deepest admiration
for bringing great honor
to this university.
Of course, at Yale, we are
ever aware of our obligation
to pair our words in support of veterans
with action that provides it.
Yale, I'm proud to say,
is routinely recognized
among the best colleges in
the nation for veterans,
in part due to our commitment to ensuring
that a Yale education is
affordable for everyone,
such as through our participation
in the Yellow Ribbon
program, just as an example.
We strive also to honor
and support our servicemen
and women through the
Yale Veterans Network,
a campus group for
students, faculty and staff,
and the Yale Veterans
Association for all our alumni.
And beyond our campus meanwhile,
the Yale Law School is helping
to rid the veterans benefit
system of racial disparities.
We have many from the
law school here today.
By supporting our veterans,
we affirm our unending
appreciation to them
for strengthening our society,
indeed sustaining our society,
through their service and sacrifice.
So I wanna close by shifting
from Yale's efforts to yours.
"The ultimate test of
a person's conscience,"
said Senator Gaylord Nelson,
"may be their willingness
to sacrifice something today
"for future generations
"whose words of thanks will not be heard."
So today, let our words
of thanks ring out loudly
to reach those veterans in our community
who have passed this test
and the service members on campus
who have enlisted to join them.
The valor of Yale's veterans is a source
of tremendous pride to this university,
and I want to thank you all once more
for being here today and for helping us
to honor them and you.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(band performing "The
Star-Spangled Banner")
- [Sergeant] Color Guard, order.
(rifles tapping)
Ceremonial at ease.
- Sorry, sir.
Good afternoon, I'm Violetta Ware
co-chair of the Yale Veterans Network
and I'm here to recite the invocation.
If those of you who could stand,
please stand at this time.
Grand Architect of the
Universe, called by many names,
in many languages, by many voices,
today we ask that your
guiding hands hold us
and all sisters and brothers
in military service near.
We are grateful for all who now serve,
all who have served,
and all for those who,
in the words of President Abraham Lincoln,
"gave the last full measure of devotion"
in service of their country.
We are joined in humility, gratitude,
and our own measure of devotion,
knowing that as we seek to understand
an increasingly complex world,
we are sheltered by the vigilant service
of citizens to our republic.
We ask special regard
for those who have served
but who have not yet been
found and returned home,
and for those who have returned
but who have yet to
find themselves at home.
We honor our military and ask
that whatever is required
of them be informed
by your infinite wisdom,
the light and the truth
as they honorably and loyally seek
to create a peaceful and
secure future for us all.
Àṣẹ, you may be seated.
- All right.
Whew.
Good afternoon everyone.
First I'd like to recognize
and thank President Salovey.
Secretary Goff-Crews, Provost
Strobel, Dean Pericles Lewis,
Chaplain Saltiel, and the
Veterans Day Committee.
I'd like to personally
thank Dean Risa Sodi,
Ms. Patricia Wei, Mr. Jack Beecher,
Haad Hyder, Dean Chandhoke,
and all of my fall-term professors
because they will inevitably
influence my GPA in a few weeks.
(audience laughing)
Most importantly, I'd like to thank
the veterans, reservists,
National Guardsmen,
active-duty service members,
civil service members,
firefighters, law enforcement personnel,
and their families who willingly sacrifice
and endure more than most will ever know
for being in attendance.
To everyone else, thank you for being here
and supporting this event.
It's truly an honor to have been selected
and given the responsibility
to provide my remarks here today.
Although I will describe what
Veterans Day means to me,
I wanna emphasize that I do not intend
to have the last word on
the meaning of Veterans Day
or how we should observe or honor it.
Today my only goals are to
underscore the importance
of unity in our society,
thank those that have had
and will continue to have a
profound impact on my life,
and honor the sacrifices of veterans
and uniform service members.
To me, Veterans Day is
not meant to be exclusive.
It is not a day for
civilians to thank veterans
and uniform service members,
and it is certainly not a day for veterans
and service members to
rest on their laurels,
bask in America's gratitude
and become complacent.
To me, Veterans Day is
inclusive to all Americans
and it is meant to remind us
of the importance of unity.
It is a day for all Americans
to acknowledge the fact
that America's freedom was achieved
and is maintained through
the selfless sacrifices
that have transcended and
continue to transcend every group
and every class of American society.
Each year, Veterans Day
provides an opportunity
for civilians to thank those
who have served for their sacrifices,
but simultaneously, it provides veterans
and service members with a
chance to thank the civilians,
mentors, friends, and family
members that have supported
and continue to support them
throughout their journeys.
For those of us who have served
and are currently serving,
this day should remind
us to lead by example,
keep striving for greatness,
and live our lives in a way
that would make those we knew
who paid the ultimate sacrifice proud.
But perhaps most importantly,
Veterans Day is meant to remind us all
that freedom is not free, it
is realized through action
and it can only be maintained
when, as Americans,
we unify and collectively
support each other
in our efforts to improve our society
and create a better world.
Before I get into my military service
and my path to becoming a veteran at Yale,
I'd like to share a bit about myself.
I grew up in southern Minnesota,
in a town of less than 2000 people
with my mother, father,
sister, and brother.
My siblings and I had a tough upbringing
in what I would consider
to be a broken home.
We had little money, my parents
were addicted to opioids
and different forms of abuse
were common occurrences in my household.
I've often been asked about the decisions
and actions that I undertook to persevere
through adversity in my childhood,
what made me different than those
who went through similar struggles
but ended up in different places,
and what lessons I've
learned along the way.
In response to those questions,
I always say two things.
First, when faced with adversity,
leaders do what needs
to be done regardless
of how unpleasant those
actions and decisions may be.
The second and more
important thing I say is
that there's no such thing as self-made.
When I needed to get away
or have a place to stay for a night,
it was the Borniki and Westfall families
that opened their homes and provided me
with the support I needed.
I was not different, I was not unique.
I did not persevere through the adversity
of my adolescence on my own.
Leaders in my community rallied around me.
They gave me encouragement
during dark times
and they held me accountable
when I needed it most.
It took a village to build me up
and show me pathways to success,
and I am forever grateful for
their support and leadership.
My experiences in the
military were no different.
In 2010, I joined the military
to provide support for my family
and create a promising future for myself.
But shortly after enlisting, I learned
that personal and professional
success would not come easy.
I spent the first two years
of my military service
in training where I struggled
to build strong personal connections,
failed far more than I succeeded
in my professional endeavors,
and neglected to reach out and be there
for my family who I
claim to be supporting.
It wasn't until I arrived at my first unit
at Fort Bragg, North Carolina that I began
to achieve more consistent success
and gain perspective that I needed.
When I arrived at Fort Bragg,
I met two individuals that
forever changed my life,
one who is here today and one who is not.
The one who is with us here today
was Second Lieutenant Chris
Brown, now Major Brown.
When I arrived at my unit, I
was arrogant, loud, selfish.
I wasn't a good friend,
I wasn't a good teammate,
and I definitely wasn't a leader.
Like the others, Chris had every reason
to distance himself from me,
but instead he coached, challenged,
and mentored me in all areas of my life.
His methods were often non-traditional,
but they were effective.
From politely encouraging me
to put on a gas mask and body armor
and run a half marathon at
lunch in 100-degree heat,
to quizzing me on radio
communications procedures
that were last relevant
during World War II,
he taught me a few valuable lessons.
By providing me with a
half marathon for lunch,
he taught me that you have
to do what others won't
to achieve what others don't.
By running those half marathons with me,
he showed me that as a leader,
you can never ask somebody to do something
that you wouldn't do yourself.
And by quizzing me on the
communications techniques
of World War II soldiers, he taught me
that you can learn
something from everyone.
Chris taught me how to be a friend,
teammate, and leader,
but most importantly,
he taught me what it means to be a man.
Thank you, Chris.
(Bobby and audience applauding)
The second person I met at Fort Bragg
was Staff Sergeant Brandon Cullen-Towle.
Brandon and I had a lot of similarities
and he was one of the only people
that I talked openly with about my past
and the loss of my father.
After telling Brandon about my reason
for joining the military and
my commitment to my family,
he held me accountable and encouraged me
to be more involved with
my mother and siblings.
Upon noticing my inability
to build strong personal
connections and friendships,
Brandon invited me to weekend gatherings
and made me a part of his friend group.
And he advocated for me
as an asset to the unit
and the broader military family community.
Nevertheless, Brandon
and I's friendship ended
on August 25th, 2012 when he passed away
in a motorcycle accident in
Spring Lake, North Carolina.
Brandon served three tours in Afghanistan,
once receiving the Purple Heart.
Brandon was and is known
for the profound impact
that he had on the lives
of everyone he knew.
And today, his influence continues
to positively affect those that knew him
and those that never did.
Brandon's sister,
Kaylee, and Brother, Kam,
are with us here today.
And each year in Dover, New Hampshire,
their family organizes a memorial event
and provides a scholarship
in Brandon's name.
Brandon's impact in life
and death should remind us
that the way we live our lives
and the imprints we put on this earth
are lasting, they have meaning,
and they could change someone else's life.
Thank you for being here
today, Kaylee and Kam.
(Bobby and audience applauding)
I share these two stories with you today
because Chris and Brandon
exemplify the selflessness,
empathy, and leadership that most veterans
and service members leverage
to create impact on a daily basis.
Outside of selfless sacrifice
and defense of freedom and democracy,
veterans provide two
broad things to society:
leadership and perspective.
Regardless of branch,
occupation, or combat experience,
veterans appreciate and embody
transformational leadership.
They give their subordinates the space
and responsibility to succeed or fail,
but they're always around and willing
to build their people back up.
Veterans know that when
you dare to be great,
you either win or you learn.
They know and believe this
because their lives depended on it.
As leaders, veterans prioritize empathy
and individualized consideration.
And when times get tough,
veterans never let others
struggle on their own.
Struggle and suffering
are necessary for growth
and throughout life, every
person is subjected to both.
But when these unpleasant conditions
leave one lost and without direction,
veterans are often uniquely positioned
to provide the perspective
that most do not have.
Veterans understand that no matter
what you're going through,
no matter how difficult and
troubling your situation may be,
there is someone else who
went through something worse
and they probably dealt
with it more gracefully
than you are currently.
These selfless individuals
have an intimate understanding
of hardship, and when veterans integrate
into the civilian populace,
they benefit the collective
by eliminating defeatism
and creating hope.
Living veterans provide
significant value to our society.
But it is the fallen
veterans that provide us
with an example of what
we should aspire to be.
Fallen veterans remind us to be selfless
and to prioritize the
mission and the people.
But perhaps most
importantly, they remind us
that we could be far greater
than we currently are.
Today in 2023, our society
is in need of unity
and one way to work toward
achieving that unity is
by bridging the military-civilian divide.
In my opinion, places like Yale University
offer the perfect environment
to work toward that goal
and unity can be realized
through interactions
between Yale's traditional students
and the university's veteran community.
Yale's traditional students
challenge veterans in many ways,
and they're critical in forcing veterans
to consider new perspectives
and embrace innovative ways of thinking.
That said, it is not lost on
me that as I stand here today,
I'm in the presence of
some of America's heroes.
And each day as I walk around this campus,
I'm thankful that Yale's
traditional students
have the opportunity to learn from them.
Heroes like Chris Hallows, Jimmy Hatch,
Connor McEvoy, Danny McCoslin, Will Myers,
and Steve Scheffer are some
of the greatest veterans
and active-duty service members
that our country has to offer,
and they provide more
experienced knowledge,
and expertise to Yale's
traditional students
than I could put into words.
However, these men and the
many male and female veterans
that I did not mention offer much more.
They're sons, daughters,
brothers, sisters,
husbands, wives, fathers, and mothers
and in my opinion, they
can teach us a whole lot
about how to live a wholesome
life and be a good person.
To the ROTC cadets and students aspiring
to serve in attendance,
I wanna personally thank
you for your selflessness
and willingness to serve our country.
After Yale, you will have the option
to do whatever you want,
and with a Yale degree,
you'll be choosing one
of the most difficult
but rewarding paths.
Serving the United States of America
was the greatest responsibility
and opportunity that I've ever been given,
and I hope that in a few
years you feel the same way.
The world is filled with
chaos and uncertainty,
and we should all be thankful
that there are people like you willing
to answer our nation's call.
You are all heroes in your own right
and I hope you know that.
Thank you all for your time.
(audience applauding)
- Color guards,
(Sergeant indistinct) Halt.
(Sergeant indistinct)
(trumpeters perform "Taps")
(shoes clattering)
- Thank you.
All right, you may be seated.
I'm still feeling that, are you?
Yeah.
So the university recognizes
outstanding contributions
to Yale veterans with the Annual
Veterans Day Tribute Award.
The recipient of the 2023
Veterans Day Tribute Award is
to John Jack Beecher.
Now, the reality is most of us know Jack,
so he really doesn't
really need a introduction,
but I'm gonna give him one anyway.
One, because we wanna
make sure that he knows
how we see him and what he's meant to us.
And the second is because
we want a written record
in our archives of who
he was and what he meant.
Jack is a United States Air Force veteran,
retired Yale business
leader, university citizen,
and a longtime champion
for veterans at Yale.
He is with us today with
his family, welcome,
and we are thrilled to publicly
recognize his contributions.
In 2016, Jack became the inaugural
veterans liaison at Yale.
His charge from Provost Ben Polak,
whom I see in the audience,
was to create and implement a plan
to support university-affiliated
military veterans.
Now, the job was intended to be part-time,
but those of you who are
familiar with Jack know
that there was nothing
part-time about his dedication.
He was the first central
point of contact for student,
faculty, staff, and
alumni military veterans.
Jack became a champion of
veterans and a problem solver.
He supported staff veterans
through the innovative
Veterans Count campaign
and created important connections
with our student veterans,
notably those in the Eli
Whitney program in Yale College
and the veterans enrolled
in the Law School
and School of Management.
At the time, student veterans
felt underrepresented
and unheard, and Jack
became their advocate.
He listened and acted on their behalf,
building a network of leaders
and staff across the university
who valued all veterans.
This resulted in policy changes,
advocacy, and relationships
that improve the university's environment
for veterans, veteran students, and staff.
As you all know, some of our
military-affiliated students
are preparing to serve through
Yale's Naval and Air Force ROTC programs.
Many are here with us today.
Jack has been an unwavering
supporter of ROTC
and especially welcoming and helpful
when new commanding
officers arrived on campus.
He has also worked extensively
with the Yale Veterans Network,
which is our staff
veterans' affinity group,
and with the Yale Veterans
Association, our veteran alumni,
once again creating positive relationships
between veterans across the university
to improve culture and experiences.
As President Salovey mentioned,
two years ago, U.S. News
& World Report ranked Yale
the number one school in the country
for veterans and
active-duty service members.
While this was a recognition
of great collective effort
across the university,
the ranking was due in no small part
to the role that Jack played
in helping to create the environment
in which veterans,
active-duty service members,
and student participants in
ROTC are valued and respected.
Jack, if you can come up.
On behalf of our entire university
and especially our veterans,
I wanna thank you for
all of you contributed
to create a strong community of respect,
connection, and belonging
for our veterans.
This is an award that's so well deserved.
So I'm gonna give you a small
token and maybe say remarks.
One second, let me give you this token.
Thank you, Jack.
- Thank
(audience applauding)
(Jack sighs)
- President Salovey, Secretary
Goff-Crews, officers of Yale,
US military veterans and their families,
and other honored guests,
Happy Veterans Day.
Thank you for being here
to acknowledge the service
of our veterans and their families.
Well, you've already heard more about me
than you probably want to know.
I'm going to tell you more.
(audience chuckling)
During my first attempt at
college, I was a marginal student
as I was unable to balance my need
for fun with academic realities.
I withdrew, and while I like
to call it a tactical retreat,
it was actually an escape.
I enlisted in the Air Force
and served from November
1965 to July of 1969.
To put that in historical perspective,
Neil Armstrong, a Navy veteran,
and Buzz Aldrin, an Air Force veteran,
walked on the moon within
weeks of my return.
Kingman Brewster, a Navy veteran,
was the president of Yale, and to date,
the only veteran to have
served in that capacity,
however, I'm told, we're
getting another president soon.
- You never know.
- Never know.
(audience laughing)
After receiving my honorable discharge,
I was told not to wear my uniform home
on the flight from Seattle.
At that time, many Americans
blamed veterans for the war.
And while I know now that
it was misdirected anger,
I didn't know it then.
It was painful and it was embarrassing,
and I felt insulted that my service
had been disavowed and canceled.
I didn't discuss my military
experience for many years
and could never have imagined
that I'd be standing before you today
at Yale honoring veterans.
I've learned a great deal
in the ensuing years.
After the 9/11 attacks on
New York and Washington,
I was concerned with safety at Yale
and my first thought was to
find the veterans on campus
because I knew they could
be called on to stand watch
and that they would understand
and respond and serve.
In 2001, we had no way to do this.
Today we are more connected than ever.
With encouragement from relentless alumni
from the late 1960s, you
all know who you are,
and the support from
our administration led
by the daughter of a Navy admiral,
we've come a long way.
ROTC units celebrated a
decade back on campus.
There's a full-time university liaison
for Veterans and Military Affairs
and teams from admissions,
the Dean's Office,
the Registrar, Financial Aid,
and our Office of Diversity,
Inclusion and Accessibility
have extended themselves to make Yale
the university of choice
for many veterans.
The Warrior Scholar Program
was founded at Yale.
It supports enlisted
veterans who, like me,
had little awareness of
their future potential
until their military service.
And while I didn't have
the Warrior Scholar Program
available to me, I did meet
a lovely nurse from New York
who said, "Jack, you're a
really good softball player,
"but have you ever thought
of going back to college?"
I did go back for my degree
and I also married her,
and we will be celebrating
our 53rd anniversary
on November 29th.
Thank you for everything, Barbara.
(audience applauding)
I'm fond of saying that veterans
are better by being at Yale,
that Yale is better by having
veterans studying here,
and our country is made
much stronger by both.
The common bond created
by service to others,
to our community, and to
our country, is strong
and runs deep at Yale and in the military.
This bond is intergenerational
and self-perpetuating.
Veterans and alumni willingly
accept responsibility
to current students and active military.
This spring, I was contacted by a member
of the class of 1968 wanting to know
how he could support our
undergraduate veterans.
Interestingly enough, he had served
in the army a few miles
from Pleiku Air Base
at the same time I was stationed there.
He traveled from the Midwest to New Haven
to meet me and two of
our veteran students.
After dinner, he sent
a note, which I quote,
"Both of them are truly unique individuals
"and quite extraordinary
in their own ways.
"They make me proud to be a
vet who graduated from Yale."
That's from a 1968 graduate
in the darkest part
of the university's
relationship with the military.
They make me proud as well.
The intersection of Yale in the military
has incalculable
potential to improve both.
I'm proud of all that
has been accomplished,
but this being Yale, I know
the best is yet to come.
Personally, I've only
expected three things
from my military service:
the respect of those who served before me,
the respect of those who served after me,
and a flag on my coffin, which in my case,
will be the same one used to
drape my father-in-law's casket
as he was a World War II
veteran of the Army Air Corps.
I've received so much more
than that from my service,
including GI Bill support to
complete my college education,
and most importantly,
an understanding of duty
and responsibility to
myself and to others.
Today, I thank you for your
support of our veterans,
that special 11% of our
population who pledge
to defend our constitution
with their lives.
They understand what it means to be part
of something larger themselves,
and they support those who
followed in the same path.
It's very difficult for me
to describe my emotions on days like this.
I burst with pride in seeing the women
and the men in our ROTC programs,
the next generation preparing
to protect and defend us.
And my interactions with
undergraduate veterans
and active military studying here fill me
with optimism for America's future.
Their presence is a validation
of all veterans' decisions to serve.
In recent years, I've
been thanked many times
for my service to my country.
While visiting friends in Wisconsin,
I had a chance meeting with an Iowa farmer
who is a Vietnam veteran.
We talked briefly and found
that we were in country at the same time.
When we parted, he said to
me, with tears in his eyes,
"Welcome home, brother."
I feel at home and welcome at
Yale as everyone should be.
I thank you for the opportunity
to serve the veteran community here.
Happy Veterans Day.
(audience applauding)
(uplifting brass band music)
(music continuing)
(audience applauding)
(music drowns out singing)
(music continuing)
(crowd chattering indistinct)
(audience applauding)
(music continuing)
(audience members hooting)
(music drowns out singing)
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Please stand as you're willing and able.
May we go forth from this
place of profound memory
and deep meaning with
grateful hearts and souls,
grateful for the sacrifice
of our veterans and their families.
Let us never forget all they have done
to bravely protect
freedom and human rights.
From the moment our veterans
make the commitment to serve,
they were committing to a life
that would forever be changed.
May we be mindful that the life
of a veteran is always multidimensional.
It is rooted in the pride
and promise of liberation,
coupled with the ever present possibility
of peril or alienation.
All of these things are held in tension
and contain a longing for
a certain kind of peace
to revive our weary world.
As we honor our veterans and we seek
to grow closer to this deep peace,
may we embody a peace born
from wisdom and understanding,
a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy,
a peace strengthened by
courage and commitment.
And may we be blessed
this day and every day
by the shimmering light
of our God of many names,
our God who creates, sustains,
and embraces all life.
Amen.
(shoes clattering)
- We're gonna close in a
second so you can sit down.
I only have a few notes
before we sign off.
So before we go, I do wanna take a moment
to wish very happy birthday
to the United States
Marine Corps, Semper Fi.
We know it's your birthday,
so congratulations. (chuckles)
(audience applauding)
I also want to make sure that you know
that there will be a
Yale Veterans Association
Military History at Yale
Tour right after this,
a walking tour that can
accommodate about 25 people.
It'll be leaving from the
cenotaph right behind me.
And I actually wanna thank
the planning committee
and our ceremony participants.
So thank you very much
for all of that you did.
(Kim and audience applauding)
And special thanks to Tom Duffy
and the Yale School of
Music Brass Ensemble
for sharing with music
inspiring, energetic.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
We're gonna learn all,
some of us are gonna
learn all the songs, okay?
(audience chuckling)
So when today has passed and we return
to our very busy lives,
I hope that we will continue
to remember the people of Yale
who have faithfully taken
oath to protect and serve.
We are a stronger, more diverse,
and more inclusive
community because of them.
And I wanna thank you for
joining us, have a great day.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music chiming)